did you know that women leave men 80
percent of the time and if they're
college educated it's 90. so if you get
divorced it's 80 of the time like the
woman leaves and one of the number one
predictors of divorce is actually if the
woman out earns the man oh I love that I
actually love that I can't like I
actually love that you don't think
that's kind of shitty no I'm like girl
you you go get that you go get down and
like yeah you go get that like really
yeah like why is there like a lack of
empathy for Ben it's not lack of empathy
but there is because like they're
they're breaking up a family a lifelong
commitment in a home and your your
reaction is you go like go get that go
get the bag sis or like I'm so happy for
you when that's actually a really like
that's a sad situation like your wife is
leaving you